à bord de ce bateau un homme partant à
la recherche d'un animal mystérieux
dans un monde hostile et placé au bout
du voyage
un impressionnant face à face avec un
prédateur puissant vorace est tout à
fait surprenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc
à l'origine de cette aventure un rêve un
rêve inspiré par le souvenir d'une
mauvaise rencontre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le lieu où se déroulait ce rêve est une
région isolée au bout du monde un chaos
de rock et de glace où naissent courant
vents et tempêtes l'antarctique
l'auteur du rêve s'appelle lionel mais
il est suédois cinéaste animalier
spécialistes de la plongée en eau froide
il filme depuis dix ans les animaux
vivent dans ces milieux extrêmes
s'il y aura ne s'aventure aujourd'hui
dans cette contrée lointaine est hostile
c'est pour retrouver un animal qui le
hante
il pense pouvoir le trouver à pete
island une île australienne de toute
glace terre d'asile de milliers de
manchots pendant la courte saison de
reproduction
à peine arrivé
yoran à la certitude que la création
s'ils recherchent fréquentes bien cette
zone
[Musique]
la voici en pleine action
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce superprédateur règne sur un immense
territoire un désert de glace aussi
vaste que l'europe 14 millions de
kilomètres carrés on l'appelle
d'ailleurs le septième continent
les températures peuvent descendre
jusqu'à moins 90 degrés et les vents
dépassent parfois 300 km heure
extrêmes sont aussi les saisons avec une
alternance de nuits sans fin et de jour
continuellement ensoleillé que la vie
puisse exister dans de telles conditions
semblent tenir du prodige en réalité les
eaux glaciales qui ceinturent ce
continent sont parmi les plus riches du
club
elle baigne au nord-ouest la péninsule
antarctique le long de laquelle ces
graines d'innombrables il
parmi elles puent thaïlande où rôdent
celui que certains surnomment le
seigneur des glaces son festin terminée
il nous révèle sa véritable identité
il s'agit d'un phoque mais d'un phoque
pas comme les autres 450 kg pour 3
mètres de long fourrure acheter mâchoire
monstrueuse son vrai nom et le léopard
de mer on connaît assez bien la
diversité de son régime alimentaire du
krill des oiseaux marins et même des
proies aussi énorme que des phoques
crabiers ou des otaries en tout 16 kilos
de nourriture par jour
pour le reste mystère ses déplacements
sa vie sociale ses amours sont encore
pratiquement inconnu et de vagues
rumeurs courent sur son compte
d'illustrés explorateurs disent avoir vu
des phoques léopard attaqué des hommes
sur la banking
alain le capitaine amène enfin yoran et
son assistant françois près du but
il aura fallu huit jours de navigation
mouvementée depuis le cap horn
pour atteindre cet endroit mythique
l'extrême sud
et avant cela de longs mois pour
préparer ce rendez-vous avec le seigneur
des glaces
quarante mètres dans lola
cette histoire a commencé il ya deux ans
par hasard je suivais des baleines de
munich est arrivé au coeur de ce
labyrinthe du lot j'ai vu mon premier
léopard de même j'avais entendu
d'incroyables histoires à son sujet
jusque là seules deux personnes
n'avaient osé l'affronter dans son
milieu
l'occasion était trop belle je me suis
mise à l'eau d'abord sans caméra pour
voir sa réaction
les des nerveux mena sont
impressionnants une morsure ici peut
être fatale
surtout si l'eau à 0° pénètre dans votre
combinaison étanche
j'y suis quand même retour
avec ma caméra en guise de bouclier mais
le lot par est devenu extrêmement
menaçant et s'est approché de moi si
près si violemment que j'ai paniqué en
fin de compte j'ai dû me contenter de
filmer avec une caméra fixée au bout
d'une perche a été l'expérience la plus
effrayante de ma fille de plongeurs en
soi un ferme ma combi un cauchemar mais
surtout un cuisant échec
depuis je ne pense qu'à une chose
retrouver le léopard de même essayer de
comprendre ce qu'il s'est passé
[Musique]
oui c'est là bas
ok on y va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme il y a deux ans l'animal le défi
avec virulence
mais aujourd'hui il rien n'est décidé à
surmonter sa peur à faire face coûte que
coûte qui de toute façon fuir serait la
pire des choses chez tout prédateur la
fuite provoque la tac
[Musique]
en restant calme et immobile il y aura
même des amorces peu à peu la pugnacité
de cette femelle
[Musique]
voilà on a lâché ferai mon pote tu
apprendras caméras les sorties de nulle
part et m'a foncé droit dessus puis la
presse cavale et la caméra c'est une
énorme femelles quant à la la gueule
ouverte c'est vraiment impressionnant
avec ses dents pointues
elle est venue ici près je voyais
jusqu'au fond de sa gorge
tiens prends ma bouteille
il était près des rochers naba elle a
pris quelques respirations j'étais
positionner juste en dessous et de la
surface
bang elle est arrivée trois sur la
caméra
je ne sais pas si c'est parce que le
léopard aperçoit le reflet de son image
dans l'optique du louvre sa gueule comme
ça mais c'est vraiment impressionnant
retournement kotick avaler une soupe et
un café chaud
cette première plongée est un succès il
y aura un à maîtriser sa peur et tenu
tête à la bête féroce de son règne il
peut reprendre son aventure là où ils
l'avaient laissée il y a deux ans
des manchots papous y séjournent tous
les ans sur les côtes de pi thaïlande
pour se reproduire et élever leurs
poussins le tout doit se faire en trois
mois entre décembre et février pendant
le cours été austral après quoi adultes
et jeunes reprennent la mer mais cette
année l'hiver s'est attardé créant un
déséquilibre dans le cycle de
reproduction des manchots papous
certains poussins ont atteint la taille
adulte et poursuivre sans relâche leurs
parents pour réclamer à manger d'autres
très en retard demande encore plus
d'attention
pour les plus petits l'avenir est bien
incertain car dans quelques semaines
l'hiver implacable sera de retour
sans parler d'un danger plus imminent
encore ces oiseaux noirs et vorace
laisse coi qui guette le moindre signe
de faiblesse
dans cette course contre la montre seul
le plus grand des deux poussins a des
chances de s'en sortir à condition
qu'ils veuillent bien courir après ses
parents pour avoir sa ration cet
exercice quotidien est un bon moyen de
sélectionner le plus fort des deux
rejetons et donc de garantir sa survie
la vie est plus calme chez les voisins
les manchots à jugulaire arrivé plus
tard ils n'ont pas eu à souffrir des
mauvaises conditions climatiques
quelques adultes rejoue les plus belles
scènes de la parade nuptiale simple
nostalgie peut-être car les poussins
sont presque tous élevés et terminent
leur nuit
les petits sont bien gras est paré pour
leur baptême de mer leur duvet a fait
place à deux films plus imperméable à
l'eau et au froid
dans cette crique isolée une troisième
espèce des manchots adélie
reconnaissables à leur tête tout noir
pour eux la saison des amours touche à
sa fin ils ne sont plus que quelques uns
à s'attarder sur cette île avant de
rejoindre la mer et ses dangers
il est entouré de forêts d'algues géante
ou musarde souvent de superbes naïade
des otaries de kerguelen
elle adore ses battre au milieu de ces
rubans végétaux mais lorsque se profile
dans la pénombre la silhouette d'un
phoque deux fois plus grand qu'elle les
voilà qui donne même élan disparaissent
pour elle le léopard de mer est une
menace sérieuse
mais celui ci semble s'intéresser bien
davantage aux plongeurs yoran met toute
sa concentration dans ce nouveau face à
face et ne s'aperçoit pas qu'un deuxième
léopard a surgi derrière
il
m
[Musique]
avec une parfaite synchronisation
les léopards de mer ses fastes aussi
soudainement qu'ils étaient apparus
yoran et perplexe que faisait ensemble
ces trois ou peut être même quatre
individus alors que les phoques léopards
sont censés être de grands solitaires
encore un mystère
[Musique]
au petit matin des manchots à jugulaire
des adultes se rassemblent sur la plage
il faudra encore quelques jours avant
que tous les jeunes soient prêts à
prendre le large et ils ont un appétit
insatiable
si bien que leurs parents sont
contraints à d'incessants voyage en mer
c'est en groupe qu'ils se rendent à
quelques 20 km de la colonie dans une
zone de pêche regorgeant de krill du
zooplancton leur nourriture favorite
seulement un léopard et l'ati patrouille
[Musique]
ils n'ont pas le choix ils doivent coûte
que coûte se jeter à l'eau et tenter de
gagner le large sans tomber entre les
terrifiantes mâchoire que les attentes
derrière lens impatiente on commence à
pousser ceux du premier rang ne peuvent
plus résister et tout le monde se
précipite à leur suite
l'un des premiers il sera
vraisemblablement sacrifier pour la
survie de tous les autres
le léopard de mer est bâtie pour la
vitesse il peut faire des pointes à 30
km heure mais il a affaire ici à des
nageurs hors pair les manchots adultes
sont vifs
puissent ils volent littéralement sous
l'eau le léopard devra dépenser
énormément d'énergie pour à peine 2
septembre les derniers du groupe décide
d'aller chercher un endroit plus sûr
pour se jeter à l'eau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais cet itinéraire est il vraiment sans
danger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
commence alors un laborieuse exode vers
une autre issue une longue marche bien
difficile quand on est dotée de six
courtes pattes
[Musique]
les léopards ont deviné eux aussi
l'intention des manchots
[Musique]
cette chasse rondement menée yoran
l'attendait depuis bien longtemps
très peu de gens ont eu le privilège
d'observer un léopard de mère deborah sa
proie et il s'y prend 2 singulière façon
après avoir 1,6 et le coût du vin chaud
il saisit un morceau de peau et commence
à dépasser sa victime en agitant
violemment la tête de tous les côtés
[Musique]
les autres manchots témoin de la tacc
quitte une nouvelle fois les lieux
l'exode reprend vers une troisième plage
de l'autre côté de l'île
le léopard n'a toujours pas consommer sa
proie
il se passe souvent plus d'un quart
d'heure entre la mise à mort est la
première bouchée
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y aura ne résiste pas à l'envié de
s'approcher pour mieux voir mais
déranger un tel prédateur en plein
festin est excessivement périlleux le
léopard paraît disposé à accepter sa
présence lorsque survient un autre
individu un vrai rival celui là bien
décidé à lui arracher sa prise
son arrivée risque de changer la donne
[Musique]
ayant dûment remis l'intrus à sa place
notre léopard prend son repas
toujours sans un regard pour le signal
il y aura ne reconnaît alors la femelle
de sa première vengé lors et elle
reconnaît aussi surpris mais enchantés
par un tel revirement
il est conscient d'avoir franchi une
étape importante dans son approche des
léopards de l'air
il peut maintenant observer à loisir la
précision la minutie avec laquelle le
carnassier arrache les plumes et la peau
du manchot
[Applaudissements]
yoran un peu trop confiants vient de se
faire rappeler à l'ordre il ya tout de
même une distance minimale à respecter
[Musique]
de sa proie il ne gardera finalement que
les morceaux les plus savoureux les
magrets il aura mis une dizaine de
minutes pour dépecer avaler loiseau ont
dit les léopards de mer capables de
dévorer près de trente manchots en une
journée
[Musique]
le groupe resté à terre arrive enfin au
bout d'une autre presqu'île dans
l'espoir de pouvoir prendre la mer sans
risque
espoir encore déçu ce dramatique jeu de
cache-cache se déroulent encore une fois
sous les yeux du suédois
et il ne veut pas en manquer une seconde
bon
pour moi
[Musique]
bon
une fois de plus les manchots ont dû
renoncer à aller pêcher
il faudra pourtant utilisé par viennent
faute de quoi leurs deux poussins
mourront de faim il y aura les papiers
d'oeuvre cette fois il ne s'agit pas de
la femelle qu'il a déjà filmé mais
puisque cet autre léopard 1ère
d'accepter sa présence
le cinéaste s'enhardit jusqu'à
l'approché de très près
de trop
[Musique]
devant un individu aussi belliqueux il
n'y a qu'une chose à faire sortir de
l'eau et vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
finalement les manchots ont découvert
une quatrième plage apparemment
tranquille
cette eau peu profonde leur inspire
confiance
un phoque leopard est bien trop gros
pour sir muscles
[Applaudissements]
avant de prendre le large il s'octroie
une pause pour se remettre de cette
marche épuisante
[Rires]
l'eau est peu profonde certes mais le
léopard prend soin d'y cacher sa tête
laissant juste dépassé son dos qui se
confond aisément avec un rocher ensuite
il n'a plus qu'à se glisser lentement
vers une proie
[Musique]
ce comportement extraordinaire qu'on
appelle la chasse du crocodile n'est pas
très courant chez les léopards de même
seuls quelques individus se seraient
spécialisés dans cette technique une
adaptation étonnante à dire victoire de
chasse bien particulier
[Musique]
partis à la recherche des bandes krill
dont se nourrissent également les
phoques léopard yoran et françois
traverse d'un étonnant laguiole les
icebergs qui se sépare des plateformes
de glace existe dans une infinie variété
de formes de tailles et de couleurs
ils ont toujours suscité chez les
voyageurs de l'océan austral une
admiration mêlée de crainte
voici le maillon essentiel de
l'écosystème antarctique le krill des
crevettes de 4 cm de long elles forment
temps n'était des essaims de plusieurs
millions d'individus
le léopard de mer sont nourris pendant
une bonne partie de l'année grâce à sa
dentition particulière un véritable
filtre à plancton
cette spécialisation est encore plus
développée chez le phoque crabiers qui
satisfait 90% de ses besoins
énergétiques avec le crir
[Musique]
de nombreuses espèces de poissons et
d'oiseaux au lift également de cette
manne
[Musique]
mais si le crime fait partie du régime
des plus petits il intéresse également
les plus grands notamment les baleines à
bosse elle commence tout juste à se
remettre des années de chasse intensive
qu'elles ont subi
malgré cela elle s'approche toujours des
hommes incapables de résister à la
curiosité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la rencontre avec ces géantes
incroyablement gracieuse a été l'un des
moments les plus forts de ce voyage
c'est impossible d'exprimer avec des
mots les changes qui s'opèrent quand un
animal de cette taille vient à vous
et se trouve là
soudain tout près
à vous scrutez de son atout est
malicieux
[Musique]
et le plus émouvant c'est de voir avec
quelle adresse azhari va vous éviter
comme si vous étiez un autre infiniment
précieux vraiment je ne suis pas près
d'oublier ce moment magique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un grand jour aujourd'hui pour les
manchots à jugulaire
il aura ne connais bien ces oiseaux il a
remarqué une certaine invitation dans
les colonies et il sait ce que cela
signifie à pareille époque le premier
rendez vous avec des lots un groupe de
jeunes a pris résolument la direction de
la plage
le chef de file avec sa crête d'iroquois
est évidemment le plus aride mais tous
ont l'air d'apprécier ce premier contact
avec ce nouvel élément
une dernière vérification de leurs
combinaisons étanches et en avant pour
de nouvelles sensations
[Applaudissements]
tous les débuts sont difficiles
incapable de rester longtemps sous l'eau
ils ressemblent davantage à des bouchons
de liège car les oiseaux marins
mais un jour viendra où ils seront des
nageurs virtuoses comme leurs aînés
[Musique]
à peine at il mis pied à terre que lui
ramener témoin d'une scène a souri
l'attaquant n'est pas un léopard de mer
mais un phoque de vedel chose incroyable
car ce pinnipèdes se nourrit
généralement de poissons et de crustacés
qu'il va pêcher jusqu'à 600 mètres de
profondeur tout téméraire qu'il est le
petit kir fois a cru bon de regagner
pour l'instant la terre ferme
[Musique]
on
à
après ce bain préliminaire les jeunes
manchots sont publiquement acte a filé
vers la haute mer
mais ils ne semblent pas pressés ou
alors ils éprouvent le besoin de tester
encore leurs instruments de navigation
ah ah
avant de se lancer pour de bon notre
héros quoi va faire lui aussi des
exercices d'être là où il à pied
[Applaudissements]
bientôt le grand plongeon dans l'inconnu
et une nouvelle vie neuf mois à
vagabonder dans les mers australes
à condition bien sûr de réussir
l'épreuve du départ
[Musique]
et
line up
le lendemain la benne est plus qu une
mer de glace pilée du brh résultat de la
chute d'énormes blocs de glace qui se
sont détachés des glaciers
ce tapis de glace compliquer la vie de
tout le monde pour les petits manchots
rejoindre la mer libre n'est plus
seulement l'épreuve difficile c'est un
pari presque impossible
[Rires]
[Musique]
les manchots sont pris au piège leur
instinct leur dicte d'aller en haute mer
mais les voilà embarqués sur un terrain
impraticable et terriblement dangereux
[Musique]
mais
non
normand
on
[Musique]
la baisse est transformée en un
gigantesque terrain de chasse les
phoques léopard peuvent se gaver sans
effort de même que l'espoir
les goélands et ses minuscules pétrel de
wilson carnivores aux jo si au cours de
ces journaux faste un seul léo peut
manger jusqu'à six manchots en une heure
heureusement d'après les estimations des
yoran ils ne sont que six ou sept autour
de pick island pendant ces quelques
jours ils prélèveront à peine 3 % de la
totalité des manches opposant sommes pas
de quoi mettre en péril l'existence de
ces colonies
parfois le banquet tourne alors j
on y aura une chose est sûre tous ces
phoques leopard ne se trouvait pas ici
par hasard il savait que l'heure était
venue pour les jeunes manchots de
prendre le large
nous savions plus dans ces circonstances
il allait se passer des choses
extraordinaires mais de là imaginer
cette scène
lorsque je me suis approché les deux
manchots est encore vivant ne bougez pas
il avait l'air tétanisés
et tout à coup l'un d'eux a tenté de
s'enfuir
[Applaudissements]
le manchot était-il vraiment choqué ou à
dissimuler la mort pour échapper à son
agresseur
[Applaudissements]
notre jeune iroquoiens à trouver une
zone dégagée de toute glace pour prendre
la mer enfin c'est plutôt elle qui l'a
pris qu'importe
cette fois il y est tout excité par le
contact de l'eau ils en oublient de se
méfier
pas de chance après tous ces efforts si
près de la mer promise voilà son avenir
brusquement hypothéqué mais la malchance
peut vous lâcher aussi subitement
qu'elle vous a séduit
[Musique]
les deux protagonistes fils comme des
comètes
yoran a du mal à filmer cette course
poursuite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parra
le plongeur a enfin rejoint le léopard
et sainte croix et où sa crise il
reconnaît la femelle qu'il a déjà filmé
deux fois
[Applaudissements]
le petit iroquois parvient à s'échapper
tout est à refaire
[Applaudissements]
j'ai tout de même réussi à l'approcher à
nouveau les jouer avec son morceau comme
un chat avec une souris
ce qui m'a frappé c'est qu'elle prenait
soin de ne pas le blesser elle
maintenait avec une étonnante
délicatesse
[Applaudissements]
après avoir joué ainsi pendant un bon
moment
la femelle est revenu vers moi hénart
[Musique]
elle n'offrait son repas
elle me tendait son trophée
[Musique]
là tout d'un coup il s'est passé quelque
chose entre elle et moi quelque chose de
nouveau
on avait les larmes aux yeux
[Musique]
et encore sous le coup de l'émotion
quand elle est revenue une nouvelle fois
de faire son offrande
[Applaudissements]
elle semblait avoir définitivement
acceptée j'en ai eu la confirmation tout
de suite après elle a laissé son show
pour revenir que moi
[Musique]
la femelle léopard à ces deux heureuses
ce jour là iragne plus ému que jamais
et le manchot qui en a été quitte pour
une belle peur
et quelques accrocs dans son plumage
[Musique]
yoran elle mais a réussi à se faire
accepter par l'animal qui hantait céret
et de plus il a établi avec lui une
complicité qu'il n'aurait jamais pu
imaginer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et si presque tous restent à découvrir
sur le léopard de mer yoran est sûr
d'une chose il mérite bien son surnom de
seigneurs des glaces
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]